Parliament will discuss the previous and
upcoming European Council summits where
negotiations on the long term EU budget
to continue they are calling on the
council for an ambitious long-term
budget and recovery package together for
Europe's recovery is the motto for the
German presidency of the Council of the
EU which began on the first of July
Chancellor Angela Merkel will present
her priorities to Parliament including
finding an agreement on the recovery
plan and EU budget kovat 19 underlines
the need for EU cooperation on health
policy MEP s will debate European public
health strategy in light of the pandemic
and continue to push for an EU wide
approach Road Transport is a mainstay of
the EU economy Parliament will vote to
ensure fair competition and a level
playing field among transporters and
improve the working conditions of lorry
drivers the Trans EU energy network is
about improving the connectivity and
storage of electricity gas and oil in
the EU Parliament will vote on a
resolution calling for new guidelines to
reflect the 2030 energy and climate
targets
[Music]